österreich ist sie dort eingereist
noch vor dem offiziellen lockerungen
sozusagen und du hast mal den selbst
test gemacht wie es ist ein zu reisen
ins land da schauen wir uns erst einmal
an und dann reden darüber
nach vier stunden darf ich jetzt endlich
das hotel hier hinter mir am flughafen
in wien verlassen
denn die einreise nach österreich war
gar nicht mal so einfach wie sonst
es ging schon in berlin los die
sicherheitskontrollen haben viel länger
gedauert als sonst weil natürlich
abstände eingehalten werden mussten
es wird einen sicherheitskontrollen
immer nur einer durch gelassen und erst
als die person ihre sachen wieder
zusammengepackt hatte durfte die nächste
sozusagen durch die sicherheitsschleuse
dann ging es in den vollgepackten
flieger es war wirklich kein platz mehr
frei also man merkt die leute wollen
wieder reisen
sie hat natürlich alle masken auf obwohl
mir ein steward gesagt hat dass das gar
nicht immer so ist also er hatte schon
viele fluggäste die ihre maske nicht
aufsetzen wollten oder gar keine dabei
hatten und er sagt dass das dann schon
ein komisches gefühl durch den schmalen
gang zu gehen
als ich dann hier gelandet bin wurde ich
gleich von der polizei in empfang
genommen
ich konnte keinen negativen corona test
vorweisen ich hatte vorher kein gemacht
das heißt sie haben mich sofort auf mein
hotelzimmer begleitet hier hinter mir
das hotel ist direkt neben dem flughafen
in wien und auf diesem hotelzimmer
musste ich dann warten
irgendwann kam dann testteam hat mich
auf corona getestet mit einem
rachenabstrich vor der tür haben immer
noch die polizisten gewartet damit ja
keiner das gebäude verlässt und das
testteam hat den abstrich dann ins labor
gebracht und nach vier stunden habe ich
jetzt mein ergebnis bekommen hier auf
diesem zettel
bei mir ist glücklicherweise negativ
dass heißt für mich geht es jetzt in die
wiener innenstadt und raus auf die
straße also annika du bist befreit ganz
herzlichen glückwunsch da darfst du dich
denn jetzt freie bewegen in wien und wie
es die situation dort eigentlich weil
die maßnahmen wurden ja in österreich
schon vor deutschland gelockert deswegen
da eine geschichte klang jetzt ganz
schön hart mit polizei eskorte
ja guten morgen aus wien tatsächlich hat
die reise viel länger gedauert als sonst
also ich bin morgens um zehn losgeflogen
bis ich dann wirklich durch österreich
gehen durfte offiziell weil ich diesen
negativen befund hatte sind elf stunden
insgesamt vergangen vier davon saß ich
wie gesagt auf diesem hotelzimmer und
man muss sagen dass sich die lage hier
vor ort wirklich entspannt hat also
mittlerweile ist die zahl der
infizierten gesunken
die zahl liegt jetzt gerade bei ungefähr
1000 69 und man rechnet damit es auch in
den nächsten tagen die zwei weiter sinkt
vielleicht sogar unter die 1000
tausendermarke und man merkt es sie auch
in der stadt dass man sich jetzt wieder
auf die öffnung der restaurants
vorbereitet also lockerungen in
österreich und mit diesen hat das land
keine negativen erfahrungen gemacht oder
also es kam nicht zum anstieg der
infizierten zahl
genau die infizierten zahl ist weiter
gesunken
jetzt so weit dass man eben auch morgens
schon wieder die restaurants eröffnet
also geschäft ist es sind seit anfang
mai geöffnet und ab morgen dann eben
auch die restaurants und es gibt oder so
weiter tirol als erstes skigebiet wieder
aufmachen möchte am 29
und das obwohl er eigentlich ich gehe
als der korona hotspot galt aber auch
das skifahren soll jetzt wieder
weitergehen